on your marks get set go
there's a new superhero in town it's
lush I need your help
National City nice clash sorry then you
can keep up oh that's you what
what's the plan catch the bad girls 85%
chance of punching
for the record I got here first I let
you get here first I need your help
can you mean ah he was actually talking
you buried natural sitting nice flashes
arrey we've been working on this all
week you're tired we're tired yeah but
we needed some down times and the best
way to have fun is for us to go out to
the club and my right team flash
let's get turnt we get to see our group
go out and be twenty five year olds and
have fun for a change and so they all go
out to a club promise me if we ever do
get married we will not do that dance at
our wedding
there is a new metahuman that shows up
it was a speedster well it's gone
someone took my purse and it's our first
female speedster names trajectory here's
a question for you
purely scientific was he good-looking
no I was a little busy getting my ass
handed to me he said I know this she is
going a lot faster than Barry I want to
be fast enough to stop zoom in any
speedster that tries to hurt my friends
I would not miss the last five minutes
hey everybody the flash is back just in
case you guys didn't know most of the TV
shows they're back so I'm gonna do a
breakdown to this they have some funny
things to say about the clip what I'm
gonna do is talk about the flash footage
first and then I'll talk about the
Supergirl stuff so here we go flash
footage this actually reminds me of the
episode where they were trying to get
Barry drunk or you could think of it as
dive bar karaoke just like a different
version of them out having fun and the
really important thing is the trajectory
I actually didn't know this from
watching the previous trailers she's
going to be way faster than Barry when
we first meet her so it sounds like she
might have a version of the velocity-9
formula like a slightly different
version of that because there are a
couple different types of manmade
speedsters in the comics but on the TV
show we only know about the velocity-9
so it sounds like this other woman might
work for mercury labs I don't know how
she would have gotten a hold of the
velocity-9 formula so they might have
some other explanation for how she got
her speed but when they talk about
needing to watch the last couple of
minutes of the episode what they're
talking about is explaining how Barry
gets to Cara's earth on Supergirl the
big Supergirl crossovers next week
they've already closed all the breaches
so he has to get there somehow so
whatever this last couple of minutes of
the episode is going to be it's gonna
explain how he opens a new wormhole and
it's probably going to have something to
do with him trying to be faster to
defend his friends he's talking about
trajectory in the clip I want to be fast
enough to be zoom I want to be fast
enough to beat any other speedster that
comes along
so whatever the arc is in this episode
him achieving that goal it will lead him
to jump to Cara's earth I can't wait to
see it and the cool thing is is because
the Batman V Superman premiere was just
happening people were asking Zack Snyder
about the DC multiverse and he did say
that they are committed to a multiverse
in the movies but he did make it sound
like it's not going to connect to the
TV shows you could still choose to
believe that until they say the
multiverse of the movies is gonna be
different from the multiverse of the TV
shows you can think about it any way you
want to but I know I joked around about
crisis on Infinite Earths it just sounds
like if they did a version of that in
the movies they could still have some
sort of multiverse crisis in some future
season of the flash but I'm not gonna
hold my breath for that that seems like
way off in the distance first we have to
get Barry jumping to Cara's earth then
we have to get Cara coming to Barry's
earth and who knows where it goes from
there there's like a thousand different
comic book directions that they could go
and that says nothing about what's going
on in the other DC shows like the
time-travel legends of tomorrow show or
arrow which doesn't really get into a
lot of that stuff now look at this
device on Barry's chest it looks like
this is the reason that he gets to
Cara's earth it looks a lot like the
Tachyon device Harrison wells wore last
season to soak up extra Speed Force so
in the flash episode when he talks about
being obsessed with getting faster to
save his friends this might be what they
create or what they find at the end of
the episode that accidentally gets him
there if you didn't see the last
crossover video I did for this I explain
the two villains they're gonna face
together our silver Banshee and livewire
we've already met livewire on Supergirl
but they just tease silver banshee at
the end of tonight's Supergirl so if you
haven't watched it yet just check it out
for context for those of you that are
asking yeah they're totally doing the
comic book race thing that Superman and
the flash did they're totally gonna do
that at the end of the episode but arrow
and flash are back this week so be sure
to subscribe to get my video for that
there's a DC giveaway going on I'll
announce the winner when I post my flash
video arrow on Wednesday
there is no legends of tomorrow not til
next week and I'm still working through
all my daredevil videos so the next one
should post really soon for those asking
about my Gotham video that's gonna post
to my Facebook page it's facebook.com
slash emergency awesome in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
my Batman V Superman video with every
single comic book fight they've ever had
and you can click here for all my flash
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight